♪ ♪
>> Sean: BIG BREAKING NEWS OUT
OF VIRGINIA TONIGHT, IN THE
COMMONWEALTH, WHERE A NEW
FOX NEWS POLL HAS REPUBLICAN
GLENN YOUNGKIN SURGING AHEAD OF
DEMOCRAT TERRY McAULIFFE BY A
WHOPPING EIGHT POINTS.
REMEMBER, THIS IS A MASSIVE
SHIFT FROM JUST TWO WEEKS AGO,
WHERE THE SAME POLL HAD
McAULIFFE UP BY FIVE, AND GET
THIS, WE ARE ALSO LEARNING
TONIGHT ABOUT A MAJOR BLUNDER
FROM THE McAULIFFE CAMPAIGN
AFTER THEY MISTAKINGLY EMAILED A
FOX NEWS JOURNALIST "CAN WE KILL
THIS" WHEN THEY WERE INQUIRING
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
TERRY McAULIFFE HIRED AN
ATTORNEY WITH, OH, LET'S SAY,
BACKGROUND, WITH A QUESTIONABLE
BACKGROUND, MARC ELIAS, WHO IS A
CLINTON ATTORNEY, TO POSSIBLY
CHALLENGE ELECTION RESULTS,
SOMETHING BOTH CANDIDATES SAID
THEY WOULDN'T DO.
NOW, THERE IS CLEARLY MASSIVE
MOMENTUM BEHIND GLENN YOUNGKIN.
CAN A DEEP BLUE STATE LIKE
VIRGINIA REALLY TURN RED?
CAN REPUBLICANS TURN OUT THEIR
VOTERS AND DELIVER A MASSIVE
POLITICAL UPSET?
HERE TO MAKE THE CASE,
REPUBLICAN OF VIRGINIA NEW
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE GLENN
YOUNGKIN IS WITH US.
SEEMS LIKE A HUGE JUMP,
STATISTICALLY ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE,
IF THAT POLL IS ACCURATE OR
CLOSE TO ACCURATE, THAT WOULD
MEAN LATE BREAKING DECIDERS
BREAKING HARD FOR YOU AND WITH
EARLY VOTING SEEMING TO BE LOW,
YOU ARE AT A PRETTY CLOSE LEVEL
WITH McAULIFFE, I WOULD SAY
THAT GIVES YOU AN ADVANTAGE.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING ABOUT IT?
>> WE ARE FEELING GREAT, SEAN.
WE ARE OUT ON DAY SIX OF OUR
TEN-DAY BUS TOUR.
THE CROWDS ARE AMAZING.
WE JUST HAD A GIANT EVENT IN
AUGUSTA COUNTY, HAD OVER A
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THERE IS ENERGY ON THIS
CAMPAIGN.
IT IS NO LONGER A CAMPAIGN, IT
IS A MOMENTUM.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY A MOVEMENT,
IT'S A MOVEMENT TO STAND UP FOR
VIRGINIANS, FOR PARENTS, AND TO
REJECT GOVERNMENT CONTROL, AND
TERRY McAULIFFE HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT HE CARES MORE
ABOUT HIS OWN CAREER THAN HE
DOES FOR VIRGINIANS, HE WANTS TO
PUT GOVERNMENT BETWEEN PARENTS
AND THEIR CHILDREN.
AND IF HE DOESN'T LIKE THE
ANSWER, THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN THE
FBI COMES IN AND TRIES TO
SILENCE THEM.
THIS IS OUR MOMENT AS VIRGINIANS
TO COME TOGETHER.
WE ARE WINNING INDEPENDENT VOTE
BY DOUBLE DIGITS, DEMOCRATS
WALKING ACROSS THE AISLE IN
DROVES, AND WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
IN THESE POLLS IS EXACTLY WHAT
WE ARE FEELING ON THE ROAD.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK AT
ALL THE PEOPLE McAULIFFE HAS
BROUGHT INCOME UNPOPULAR
JOE BIDEN, 35%, KAMALA HARRIS,
STACEY ABRAMS, EVEN
BARACK OBAMA AT TERRY'S OWN
EVENTS, HE SEEMS TO BE
GETTING MORE PRESS APPEARING
THEN PEOPLE SHOWING UP FOR HIS
EVENTS.
I THINK THE MAXIMUM CROWD THEY
HAD WITH BIDEN AND OBAMA WAS
LESS THAN 2,000.
AND YOU ARE DRAWING HUGE CROWDS
EVERYWHERE YOU GO, SO
ANECDOTALLY, YOU FEELING GOOD
ABOUT IT?
HOW DO YOU ANALYZE THE EARLY
VOTING?
>> YEAH, SO FIRST OF ALL,
TERRY McAULIFFE IS DOING
EXACTLY WHAT THE PLAYBOOK THAT
HE RODE AS THE GODFATHER OF THE
MODERN-DAY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WOULD DO, WHICH IS BRING
SOMEBODY ELSE IN.
HE HAS ASKED EVERYBODY TO COME
INTO CAMPAIGN.
IF YOU EVER HELD OFFICE AND WON
OR DIDN'T WIN, HE HAS INVITED
YOU TO COME AND TAKE THE
SPOTLIGHT OFF HIS FAILED RECORD
AS GOVERNOR AND HIS FAILURE TO
LAY FORWARD AN AGENDA THAT
EMBRACES -- AND I'M TELLING YOU,
EARLY VOTING HAS BEEN GREAT.
TURN OUT FOR US HAS BEEN STRONG,
TURN OUT FOR HIM HAS BEEN WEAK.
I'VE SAID IT ALL ALONG, THE ONLY
PERSON EXCITED ABOUT
TERRY McAULIFFE'S
TERRY McAULIFFE, AND SEAN, THE
BIG THING IS, THIS RACE HAS
BECOME A NATIONAL RACE.
VIRGINIANS ARE VOTING FOR THE
NATION.
I GET SO MANY EMAILS AND TEXTS
EVERY DAY, OUR WEBSITE AT
YoungkinFordGovernor .com IS
OVERWHELMED BY FOLKS COMING IN
AND BEING PART OF WHAT IS GOING
TO NOT JUST CHANGE THE FUTURE OF
THIS GREAT COMMONWEALTH OF
VIRGINIA BUT SENT A SHOCK ACROSS
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY THAT WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE OUR COUNTRY BACK.
>> Sean: SO, ONE OF OUR
REPORTERS FOR FOX NEWS, I
BELIEVE FOXNews.com, SAYS HE
IS RIDING A STORY ABOUT
McAULIFFE HIRING MARK KELLY
US.
NOW WHAT IS INTERESTING ABOUT
THIS, A FRIEND OF THIS PROGRAM,
JONATHAN TURLEY TWEETING OUT
THEY ARE A HOST OF ELECTION
LAWYERS, BUT McAULIFFE HAS
HIRED A LAWYER ACCUSED OF LYING
TO THE MEDIA, CURRENTLY INVOLVED
IN A MAJOR INVESTIGATION THAT
HAS ALREADY LED TO AN INDICTMENT
OF HIS FORMER PARTNER.
McAULIFFE MAY BE PREPARING TO
CHALLENGE ANY WIN BY
GLENN YOUNGKIN.
AND THE RESPONSE WAS, THEY
DIDN'T MEAN TO DO IT, BUT THEY
WRITE "CAN WE GET THIS STORY
KILLED," "CAN WE TRY TO KILL
THIS?"
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THE
HIRING OF ELIAS AND THE
CAMPAIGN, OBVIOUSLY, FEELS THEY
HAVE AN IN WITH CERTAIN MEDIA
OUTLETS THAT THEY CAN GET
STORIES KILLED.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THIS JUST
IS THE EXACT PLAYBOOK THAT
TERRY McAULIFFE WROTE FOR THE
MODERN-DAY DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AND
HIS CAMPAIGN IS ABSOLUTELY
FAILING.
I MEAN, THE SUN IS SETTING ON
HIS 43 YEAR POLITICAL CAREER.
AND BY THE WAY, THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO NEED LAWYERS BECAUSE
THIS ISN'T GOING TO BE CLOSE.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN VIRGINIA
TODAY, WITH US WINNING
INDEPENDENTS BY DOUBLE DIGITS AT
DEMOCRATS WALKING ACROSS THE
ISLAND VOTING FOR US, THIS ISN'T
GOING TO BE CLOSE, SEAN.
VIRGINIANS ARE MAKING A BIG
STATEMENT.
THEY ARE MAKING A STATEMENT THAT
THERE IS A NEW DAY AHEAD OF US,
LOW TAXES, GOOD SCHOOLS, AND A
GOVERNMENT THAT WORKS FOR US,
ISN'T TELLING US WHAT TO DO ALL
THE TIME.
THESE ARE UNIVERSAL VALUES, AND
VIRGINIANS ARE READY TO STEP
FORWARD AND MAKE THIS RACE NOT
EVEN CLOSE.
>> Sean: IT WOULD BE NICE TO
HAVE A GOVERNOR THAT LIKES
PARENTAL INVOLVEMENT IN KIDS
EDUCATION, AGE-APPROPRIATE
MATERIALS BEING CAUGHT, CRT,
DRACONIAN MEASURES AS IT RELATES
TO COVID, ET CETERA, ET CETERA,
NOT BEING LECTURED THAT THEY
HAVE NO BUSINESS BEING INVOLVED
IN THEIR CHILDREN'S EDUCATION.
I DO NOT THINK THAT WAS A VER